all right is it Edwina yes all right
Edwina yes Edwina where'd you grow where
are you from originally I grew up
between Chicago and Los Angeles with my
guys traveling with between both cities
what was your childhood like uh
childhood was wonderful I should say um
a bit lonely uh maybe it was very strict
they really like people in the house
it's kind of secretive type of people so
it was a kind of strict resistance we
moved around a lot too we've seen the
same neighborhood more or less but
in many different places in San Diego so
I felt like I was always like the
eternal
stranger all the time like you see like
a new guy new kid in the black literally
all the time yeah how was your life with
your parents any abuse or anything like
that uh no everything I think everything
was really good with my mother my dad uh
was really little he was not around he
worked a lot he's a truck driver he
spent a lot of time away you know and uh
but my mom I love her
um she's from Scotland uh Joe man from
Chicago and he's like yeah she was great
you know what kind of kid were you in
high school uh very popular kid uh I
never had a problem with dates with
women I uh
ever kind of got along with all
different cooks and groups or type of
people never really uh was out you know
shunned by anyone
I would say high school is very good and
I said like that's a career did track
cross country I was very happy with that
sounds like a good childhood it was
decent childhood yeah for sure Dead
really I went out his way to to make
sure what kind of things did you want to
do with your life when you got out of
school uh I primarily worked for my
family my whole life I worked in a media
distribution business I'm sorry uh home
media distribution
so you know videotapes and duties things
like this yeah okay
and uh if you've been married had kids
I've been married for 27 years basically
prior to say they had two grown men and
Sons again
you have two kids two grown men yep okay
13 28.
and you and your wife
separated divorced yes she really tried
to bomber on me and it really effed up
my life in a major way that's really
kind of like put me in a big tangent I I
I've had a lot of diversity a lot of
tragedy in my life but the sanctity of
my marriage is the one thing that I that
I kind of held very sacred today was
that the biggest uh
hit you took in your life I think so
yeah yeah I saw I'm fortunate enough to
say that I still have my mom and dad so
I know the gay men can really say you
could be still I can say I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do that one it's gonna
win until you go through that needle you
never really know how you're going to
react I've seen men who were otherwise
stuck or whatever and and strong
disintegrate and fall apart you know so
yeah and I see those are the words that
were that were frailing those little
wimpy handled it with blind Hardy
courage so like I said until until you
approach that that moment I don't think
you can really you really can't uh you
surely can't yeah divorce is no fun
it wasn't you know I I I hate to keep
you in my mind you know reliving these
moments over and over and over
but for some reason like certain
features or things in my life that have
really harmed me or whatever driving me
around I've tendency to in my mind
revisit them over and over you know I'm
still recalled to the moment when she
asked me for her a divorce I just came
out of left field you know we had a
blessed life we had a beautiful home
time though uh just kind of downtown
what did you do after you separated uh
we had a collaborative divorce which was
cool because the military attorneys
didn't get hardly a penny
um
uh she brought me out of the account the
other way you just bought cash you give
me half cash for that and I took
everything I owned and I split what were
the reasons for the divorce from her
side of the fence
bro
it's complicated you know I we had
spoken when we were younger that
possibly maybe you should have two
spouses and you're like maybe one when
you're younger and then maybe one or
another because you diversion you
changed so much
um but like eventually see I think
intimacy is the glue that keeps the
marriage together and I think without it
I think starts going apart and
um she was looking for something orange
she found it in another guy so
and that was in Chicago yeah and uh he
came to Los Angeles when I've been back
and forth my whole life I have family in
Orange County too so I've been back and
forth but full-time uh 10 years ago 10
years ago yeah you came here yeah and
what have you been doing since then
because you're living on the street now
I am but uh you know amongst amongst the
homeless Community I think you've had
many of you there's a wide range of
diversity of people within the homeless
Community there are those that was
[ __ ] on the side of I couldn't sleep
whenever they were
I have a tendency to
try to replicate my old life but in by
my own things about my own hands so I
like to build a home to secure made a
steal locking door so that it's no
different than anyone else uh in the
academy apartment at some point you know
but this morning I found you sleeping in
front of my studio here on the street
yes I was well see my studio because I
was waiting for Jesse's open and I just
not enough
here is my favorite store in La these
people assaulted there say really really
good people you know a store across the
street yeah and Mr Robinson you uh
you dabble with drugs yes how long has
that happened uh I've been doing I've
been I would say a decent and kicked
everything in my whole life about 10
times so the whole range of everything
what are you using currently uh crystal
meth and marijuana and periodically very
periodically some some wine or some beer
when I was younger that would seemed it
was my main problem I used to drink
quite a bit alcohol too excessive it's a
blackout too anyway we're gonna do like
but then I figured you like I quit for
15 years when it's over didn't touch a
drop of anything because I want to be a
good example for my children so
what does crystal meth do for you
um I don't if if someone's ever done it
before they can quit this Tuesday maybe
a little too much coffee I mean just
talking about three or four Starbucks
coffees and you just like that I'm sorry
so it's like taking down like a couple
of steroids coffees yeah stimulant I
mean in 80s I did a lot of cocaine and I
think cocaine is a far more strong
stimulation message same message cover I
don't think so coke I would go off the
rails
I don't know do you feel like you have
your drug situation under control
absolutely yes any time in my life could
uh
any kind of life that drugs starting to
interfere with my interpersonal
relationships or my ability to make a
living I backed out 10 000 billion
percents I mean are you are you making a
living currently huh are you making a
living currently oh absolutely certainly
how do you where do you work
um I work for myself I have my whole
life so I've worked with my family but I
worked independently my life how do you
make money
um I buy and sell you I uh rented the
LACC and event at uh mccarthur Park so
I'm a good Consignment broker also
excuse me consent broker so if other
people have substance they can't sell I
will take it in Consignment and I will
sell it for them in because the park or
OCC or wholesale I have a pretty
portfolio Park it's like a little flea
market where people will sell absolutely
items right excuse me it could range
from
one or something two five thousand
something I have a clients all of them
in every there's a guy for everything
seriously there's a whole Beauty guys
and I'm trying to describe there's this
guy there's there's a place for
everything you know and I enjoy
that because I love to give things a
second purpose as opposed to being
chunked into a trash can or so I like to
close our business because I'm at 800
I'm an ecologist as well so I think it's
great I'm kind of erasing the carbon
footprint of all the 90 FPS in the world
that just buy crap and then chunk it
right right off the bat and don't even
bother to reuse it or recycle it I mean
try to listen to their car before your
friends today
um yes I recently uh lost my best friend
and I'm still mourning them it was about
a month ago I'm sorry yeah I mean
terrible terrible I came out of nowhere
too he was healthy and it but he had he
had an ongoing medical condition that
would that was one of those that was
just fine once again you can go the next
then killed him
it really yeah put me in the air it
really turned my whole even out here put
my whole life into you know just because
I was tendency to uh fix my star with
those that are on the upper echelon or
whatever they they tend to do and my
friends I run was the absolute
Undisputed boxer for my burly I mean
yeah
so he ran so what did Tyrone die of uh
is he a
DV DVC deep vein thrombosis yeah
actually has tensor or filters putting
his body to stop blood clots are
breaking loose but I guess apparently a
one broke loose and killed him so DBT
I'm sorry
it was terrible I mean I thought of all
he was a little StreetWise he was savvy
coolest guy in the world you would think
he'd be the last one standing but the
signature of Life yes you know
living on the streets is tough right
rural what kind of stuff have you been
through
uh
I can't even tell you the the level of
violence uh is astronomical the the uh
layperson could not even conceive of the
amount of violence that homeless people
face every day violence and
discrimination from
store vendors from anyone I mean
it's easy to think you're kind of
dressed as a female
yes and I don't do it all the time
because when you catch me would you
consider yourself trans or
no I would consider myself a
cross-dresser more or less yeah I would
say almost a straighter by male
um
definitely in terms of value is more
towards transgender or women I see a man
and go oh he's higher he's cute it
doesn't insert me that way you know what
I'm saying but in terms of in the
context of the bedroom is a whole other
matter people you can't really put
people's sexuality into words should I
say the worst of snowflakes and and
sexuality I know I was in the adult
video industry in my whole life too and
I know it's for every person it's so
diverse and so finite you listen to an
interview like just about that we can
spend hours and hours and hours going on
now yeah like midgets with high heels
down to the most fine I details manager
that way because they're I believe in
essence
Foundation they're original creatures so
they they only see every little thing
that maybe they saw it when they're a
little kid or when they're a young man
turned around
when you're focus on that I think it
becomes you can become The Crucible of
your of your of your you know Outlook or
sexual you know sexual desires so do you
have a romantic relationships still oh
certainly yes yes for sure and those are
with men or women uh both both yeah both
you've been in love before
other than your wife
yes
yes I have to say that my friend Tyrone
I I was in love with I loved him deeply
I mean I really really loved it deeply
and
I never really felt that way about a man
before in my life
but
I did about him because I truly loved
him I I loved everything about him he
was just and everyone in our
neighborhood he was a very popular guy I
mean people loved this guy he was a
spectacular okay so I was like I said I
was just touching my search that's uh
pretty high post I don't go for the
Bottom Feeders I just go right to the
top you know that's that's those are
lofty goals and lots of Ambitions you
have high standards and
but but they say the biggest biggest
fall so now with him being gone now
every everyone that was his Nemesis now
is looking to me and for a while
I thought I was going to take over his
position and and uh and run these uh
things that we do up there but I did for
a while and it's just it's unsavory and
it's not it's not it's not my character
I don't want I don't want to do it
that's not that's happening so I relaxed
and the moment I relaxed he he had a
rose uh previously uh to jail for some
violation before and basically the same
thing happened before I held together
for a while but then I was just
overwhelmed it's overrun because the
multitude of of of players in the game
is just so vast there's so many people
it's not just a few and you've got every
foreign gangsters and said just swirling
around to speak
conundrum of whatever so let somebody
else handle it that's something no idea
what does your typical day look like
uh usually uh usually I wake up you're
using crystal meth how often do you
sleep
I sleep pretty regularly if I push it to
a two-day stand up it would be the same
thing I did when I was when I was uh
drinking coffee so cigarettes with my
dad it was the same thing if a certain
job required it I would say but
Tuesday we would get up
certainly uh you know look at my place
make sure the security is always a huge
money sincerely make sure that anything
is it's a of any value or anything put
away or locked down and then get the
recyclables inches they're still here
right away in the morning because it was
the number one target for theft get that
money uh Parliament possibly into things
that are needed uh tools and this and
then start to work on on
um
whatever I I also I I used to art also
has to repurpose Furniture I like to uh
work with Street and sea glass so like
this in a different way that's
you still have contact with your family
I do I do I have a cell phone that I
call my mom on and my dad and I watch
porn those are three functions of their
cell phone search for what about your
sons uh I I have spoken to them and
we're not as strange or anything like
this it's just I don't speak them on a
regular basis I'm very proud of both
they're both very successful are you
aware of your current situation oh yeah
yeah my boys know I'm a crazy ass
they've known it since they were little
boys and we we lived in a very because
because my feelings esteeming with about
a million baby we always lived in a
really nice upscale areas and they knew
that their dad was always different than
their dads the other guys were stock
Brokers or Commodities guys or just that
we all went to Ivy League schools in
Notre Dame or simple so I just so they
were of one cut my sons always knew that
I was I was
eccentric
which was a great way I'm glad I'm glad
you hit your Century my mom even said
essentially many people have said
extensions and and it's just you know
mama said I could dangerous poppers or I
could use it I I like to think so you
know I I have a tendency to speak a
little too fast sometimes and I was
trying to say I have a very high
vocabulary and a lot of expression
thought and I have a tendency to talk
too fast because I feel my life is
getting away from me and I have a lot
inside of me that I want to get out and
and give people these knowledge or
insights that I have but I just don't
feel like I have enough times on going
faster that I refuse to dum dum my
vernacular to the local public hey yo
what's up like I don't speak like that
you know I say I would think that
someone who was uh who spoke with it
would find more patronizing if I did
that as opposed to speak the way I don't
really speak you know I mean how old are
you uh 57 57 yeah
what would you say is your biggest fear
uh this point in your life
it's cliche but probably dying alone I'm
sorry it's cliche but probably dying
alone by myself like I figure
you know I I don't want to die in the
cold either I have a really I'm getting
quite full of other colds and it it
really affects me it was very cold last
night
it was very cold last night it's cold
for this winter it's been a cold winter
I mean you're walking around Barefoot I
had a pair of comic books on yesterday
and I blew this off of one of them in
frustration and anger I whipped them in
the middle of a liquid Boulevard in
Venice it comes up
so you travel around town I do and I
think that's the part of the success of
my of my brokerage is affected what's
coming in one neighborhood not
necessarily has never been seen before
another neighborhood I mean everybody's
got one of these little widgets already
in this neighborhood but actually and
you heard these people don't have them
so it's just good are you content with
this lifestyle
I am and this homeless Vagabond
lifestyle I am because I lived
I said the first 50 years of my life
along the way but pretty much you know
really living my life for my children
and my life and now I'm doing pretty
much it's the opposite yes and it's
exciting to be to be to have an
unbredded do anything you want to do
that's fantastic you like the freedom
and lack of responsibility
more or less likable we're heading on my
own Shanty they build on public land
around
I mean my mom actually come home all the
time when I sweetheart she says son
please come home please they have a
large Mansion they live in I get on my
own floor my own balcony but I tell her
I said man I should recall we just come
to my house when I was 40 years old and
I hit my head in my hands and I'd be
like oh my God I'm jumping from a
trainer I had a huge friend I mean
financial success but still financial
burden and worry when you have that
amount of money and stuff [ __ ] happens
and I was always I was always upset
about it because it's just not my
I'm not you know I'm just not one of
those guys I mean I'm a very simple
person and I I don't need a lot of uh a
lot of materials because I never have I
need a lot of material things to be
happy if I find one or two small things
that I really enjoy I keep them and
covered them for a long time
a hoarder I don't want a million stuff I
just I just want one that I like you
know like that
if you had your life to live all over
again Edwina what would you have done
differently
uh
I think I I tried to join the military
when I was younger my mom and dad
provided me for doing so
um probably for a good reason because
I'd probably be dead right now I don't
think I would survive I'm a Fanatic in
many regards and when I when I when I
[Music]
but I am very proud of my country and I
love my country and I think that I would
certainly have done good some good
service you know
I I'm pretty frenetical about Firearms I
love I love uh my guns I love them a lot
yeah I grew up with them and to me it's
very natural and very um
I think everyone should have one I mean
it really it really levels the playing
field again it's tough Crooks from
employees from pushing people around
when they're done so we can smoke their
ass right in the spot it really is just
they're doing her pretty fast you know
what are you proudest of in your life
what are you proudest of in your life I
would say definitely my my YouTube
children they're both very successful
men in their in their own field
uh
I'm happy that I that uh I know in my
heart my soul that I will go to heaven
and see my relatives I'm very proud of
my Catholic faith I've been obsessed
with my whole life and I still practice
right now you know and
um
what was the the lowest point of your
life what was the most difficult period
I would say either the divorce obviously
it's just Arena but
um previously my mom had a double
mastectomy uh and they didn't know she's
gonna make it or not she had breast
cancer and I think that that like one
month period there it was attention ago
was through the worst period worst time
in my life I was absolutely
not responsible for my actions I was I
would say clinically probably insane I I
I I I love my mom so much I worried
about her so much that I think I gave
myself a quasi nervous breakdown slash
all these things thrown into one thing I
mean I really went up the rails crazy
your mental stability always been an
issue
no no I
I have to say probably maybe a little a
little more uh-skin than I should be you
know like I would take these things that
people say he's kind of it's more to
heart or too much heart should I say or
and I suppose I don't worry about that
character but I would sit there and
worry about even if it was someone who
was insignificant I would say why would
that every guy say that to me about this
why like over and over and over but my
mentality is never really um I've never
really I suffered from depression when I
was younger but even in in a minor way
not like some like deep periods of
depression just uh you know I had some
uh
issues with uh with uh when I did with
this Partners being a pedophile and that
really uh kind of checked my
early life and in terms of sexuality how
I viewed things who was a pedophile
my videos business partners yeah one of
your what does one of my dad's business
partners one of your business partners
yeah yeah how old were you in this uh I
was a young man I was really like 11
years old you know so did something
happen with you oh absolutely uh I mean
host these big dinner parties and yet
and we have those couples over and of
course like little kids would be you
know the rails upstairs watching what's
going on but once up periodically we
would be invited to The Tenors as well
so we would sit there and uh his name
was Frank it's uh this hey ho who
molested me
um
he uh he was a bachelor all the time he
was never really brought a wife or a
date or around everyone else is like
Mary you know but um he had said uh I
need someone to cut my lawn on the
weekends yeah and my last like I quit
her to say actually I paid five dollars
and in the 70s that was a lot of money I
was like I'm like that dad's gonna do
this he said oh sure he said so
it says first time I mean first time
there he's showing me dirty blokesness
of that and but these people are they're
they're some are very estimate suit and
how to manipulate young minds he played
it around so much so he got me thinking
that if I'd said anything or did
anything I was gonna hurt my mom and dad
and who would never have these parties
never so but it's just escalating got
worse and worse over the course of time
and this is cereal like honestly over
and over
um until I couldn't figure out a way of
getting out of it as I say as a young
man I could I didn't want to I couldn't
say anything to my dad so I started to
like fake you know oh I feel sick right
allergies I can go my jet is a very high
worker I was like you just get your ass
up you know I bet you're doing this
um eventually I don't know how it stops
but
um I accept that a secret I didn't tell
another human being about it until I was
in my 30s believe it or not that's a
terrible thing I don't think if I could
give advice to any young person or
anything is I know it might be difficult
or hard to talk about things that are
diverse or adversity you've had or
problems or even things are bad things
on your mind whatever I definitely know
it's better to uh because I already to
get it outside a single therapist
yeah absolutely I I can tell I I
reservedly
I I'm happy with the way the way I am
who I am how I am but I think if I would
have done it more I would be more am
than I am right now which is cannot for
me the way I'm feeling would be good
look at it yeah
hmm yeah what's your biggest regret uh
biggest regrets
I don't have a lot of regrets you know
there aren't really many really major uh
Milestones or markers in my life where I
said [ __ ] I wish I should have made this
decision instead of that decision
instead you know
um life has its ups and downs it does
have some jobs but I would just say I've
lived a pretty Charmed Life thus far
I've seen it's been a lot of a lot of
upsources of certain times of course but
yeah what was your favorite memory as a
kid
or in your life
I have to say that my favorite
day Deja they're very few they're very
rare but uh Mom and Dad both works when
I was when I was coming up and um
there's a HTML truck driver in the city
LCL means lesson
skid different locations it was just
hard you did Bigfoot three foot in the
city but Mom was awake yourself so but
she would plan her schedule around my
school and around his job back but
periodically I'd be secrets to that and
she couldn't take care of him so bad
that would take me to work with him in
his truck he only happened he only have
about three or four times there was as a
little boy did nothing for me but
blooming I loved right around the semi
tractor the lifestyle the instructions
[ __ ] everybody out the window like they
just do what they want to do that's like
they said they're like Ultra Macho Man I
mean like really as opposed to you know
I thank you take a number sir like these
guys just like do it too and we were
shopping in north central Chicago get
like the big Garden dog hot dogs and
getting paid like in the 70s like 27 an
hour for like sitting in this cab
waiting for an hour and a half before
other guys to drop off their delivery
before you can deliver this sick
here's a Teamster using team sir so I
mean those are those are those that are
literally also we I was very good very
good athletically so and I took my
little league teams to championships
almost every team I was on one their
daily championship because I pitched
that's great extraordinary and we
recruit each other a good pitcher so
those are good memories too yeah for
sure
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the most important lesson I've learned
in my life is uh
uh don't paint everyone with a with a
with a wide uh otherwise with a white
pressure white stroke coming up uh
nothing against my Ford radio yellow but
uh she he raised in an extremely racist
and uh and violent way he grew up in
Southwest Chicago and for for necessity
in his life he had he had to be this way
black beavers versus whites south side
of the sky was a very tumultuous and
Affinity in their 60s very challenges uh
a lot of things going on and just a
matter of survival so
I learned that you can that people are
people humans are humans you know for a
long time I wasn't that way I learned
for a long time a long long time I mean
I was a hardcore I mean almost like you
know Nazi bordering like racist I mean
how always
but that you see you can kind of tell by
my demeanor you hardly know me but if
you spend a little time with me you
understand my character is that is the
absolute opposite of what my character
is I'm I'm a loving and caring person I
assume Tyrone was a African-American
yeah for sure you know so
[Music]
was the emphasis of of what I really was
because around that then my mom would
always be not so much about the racism
but mama was embrace me and say please
do anything you want you're great you're
smart you're handsome don't anybody tell
you anything else and just give me the
confidence uh you know
through
many things that many people without
confidence just don't because they're
asking you shall receive many people
just don't want one because it goes to
do something I always
look at hey
no I mean
beat a job interview where this is that
I mean you just said something there
sometimes even nowadays I do things that
other homes people don't do because
I just do because I have more nerves
than they do like this and I'm not
afraid
most people are down by law around here
they have so many warrants there's so
many uh baggage they're worried about
sneezing and going back to the Joint you
know what I'm saying me I've got a
record yes please I there's I'm not
afraid to engage the police state that
I'm not doing anything that we just did
you've done time for for what uh uh
you know that fences right yes your
current fence yes I was probably Numero
Uno in in the whole world so buying
stolen item yeah yeah buying stolen
merchandise to resell it absolutely not
a wholesale business I'm talking about
semi Falls like not little Doodle stuff
for cruise guys
what would you say is the most but what
does the world need most at this point
uh the world needs
I think the the world needs for God or
our geneology well however this is going
to work it's about is the mankind has to
undergo some Quantum Leap in terms of
their uh
it's just spirituality in the thought
process and everything the way the way
it stands right now
recently more enlightened as far as as
far as science or as far as technology
but it doesn't seems they're getting
more enlightened in terms of their inner
personal relationship with their fellow
man you know it's actually God is
amazing that's what the way you were
aware I don't it's going to take
millions of years for us to evolve
because through journalism
there seems to be a lot of hate and
judgment
great racism in the world absolutely
absolutely and
I I really boiled down to
my viewpoint on most things has become
so cynical that ultimately I think
everything is [ __ ] it all comes out
of money and I never thought it was I
never thought I would think that as a
young man I decided because I'm an
ideologist myself so if I like I said to
an ideology or a thought or an idea I
want to go with it but
I'm a learning person in my home and
show you I had a large amount of library
and I mean I studied about all four
stuff and specializing like bolsterism
and Russian history but
I had a friend who was an uh ex Patriot
from from Thomas Jefferson and he was a
very intelligent man he spoke about 10
different languages I mean he was a a a
Community currency a Trader and um
he summed up in three words
what I had hundreds of books a hundreds
of thousand millions of words of
studying these topics and ultimately he
said to me Jerry dog eat dog and it
struck me like a bullet head
that is a plastic dog each dog they use
religion they use all these things as a
French as a guise for always the same
[ __ ] it's a minority
rolling over a majority of people it's
wealthy people playing poor people it's
all about to me I mean my my sister will
be fine I see you guys all about money
anyway
I really like I said before visual
creatures so of course they see things
when you see things you covet them you
want them right so that's fine then rack
up cars and this and so wow material
things sound great but then they're
sitting in a big house with other [ __ ]
around now
you want to become powerful right so
they open every company so you must be
around or they run for political office
and that's fine too I have no problem
that we need leaders we need bosses but
the critical plot I find it was manual
and you may probably agree with me is
that
at that point they transcended and they
want to become God it's been proven
throughout how history Pharaoh Hitler's
son you were a Guardians God I'm from
God and that is when God will strike you
down because there's no one is God but
there's only one God having above us all
and when you think you're a God that's
when uh you're gonna be a big trouble as
I could say in other two be nice to
everybody in the way up because you're
gonna see him on the way down so
all right Edwina thank you thank you so
for sharing your story
I wish you the best of luck out here
great thank you very much